now I'm going to talk about a people
that began to settle and eventually
conquer much of Anatolia modern-day
Turkey at the beginning of the second
millennium BCE and these people are
known as the Hittites and the word
Hittite is referred to in the Hebrew
Bible in the Old Testament and it's
worth
dissecting that word a little bit
because the word comes from the idea
that this region that they conquer in
modern-day Turkey was referred to as
Hattie and Hattie had original
inhabitants known as the Hattie ins but
the Hittites conquer and displace these
Hattie uns but they are referred to as
the Hittites because they cut they
settle in Hattie now they're considered
to be indo-european people this is a
word that you will hear often in world
history and that's because what
linguists have found is that many modern
languages seem to have a root in what's
called proto-indo-european language and
I'll do a whole video on it but looking
at linguistic structures we believe
we're one model is is that many of the
people who speak these indo-european
languages or these ones that are derived
from that proto-indo-european and that
includes
the Greek and languages related to Greek
we're talking about Latin we're talking
about the Germanic languages including
what I'm speaking right now which is
English which is fundamentally a
Germanic language with a lot of Latin
influence we're talking about Celtic but
we're also talking about more Eastern
languages like Persian and Hindi and
Bengali all of these have a lot of
commonalities to them which which we
believe gives evidence that at one point
it was a very closely related group of
people who are coming from this Caucasus
region and this map that you see here
this shows one model for how those
people spread and eventually broke off
into various tribes speaking different
but very related languages so for
millennia the 4th millennium BCE they
were since they were in this region
right over here which would be southern
Russia the Caucasus right around there
and then by 2500 BCE that's
orange area they had spread even further
and then by 1000 BCE they had spread
even further and the Hittites would have
been one of those people because they
settle in Anatolia right over here now
we don't know as much about Hittites as
we know about say the ancient Egyptian
or the Mesopotamians but we know that
they were a significant civilization now
if you look at this timeline here it
shows the various civilizations that
were emerging around this time we're
down talking about the the mid to late
second millennium so this is 1700 BCE
I'll write that down just to make sure
we know that's BCE 1600 BCE so on and so
forth and I show these various
civilizations that existed around that
time so when you and they should they
correspond to this map here so you have
Mycenaean Greece which emerges around
1600 BCE all the way to about 1100 BCE
you have the New Kingdom of Egypt which
is from about 1550 BCE to a little bit
after 1100 BC and we do a whole series
of videos on ancient Egypt and then we
talk about the Old Kingdom the Middle
Kingdom and of course the New Kingdom
and the New Kingdom of Egypt is
important because they're going to be
one of the key rivals for the Hittites
in this period the New Kingdom of Egypt
is often referred to as the Egyptian
Empire because it was the most powerful
time of ancient Egypt now and you see
that right over here in this brown color
now in this purplish blue color that is
the Hittite civilization and this map
right over here you can see that they
started to really settle and conquer
that area at the beginning of the second
millennium and by 1600 you have the old
hittite kingdom and then as we get to
about 1400 BCE you have the new hittite
kingdom often known as the Hittite
Empire and this is where they really
start to flex their muscle and notice
they're flexing their muscles at roughly
the same time as the Egyptians and so
this map right over here this is in
roughly the 14th century what
this area look like so we're talking
roughly this zone and you can see there
are several civilizations many of them
that were in their peak you see the
Mitanni kingdom right over here you see
the middle Assyrian Empire and we talk
about them when we talk about
Mesopotamia and you see Kassite
Babylonia right over here the calf sites
took over after the amorite under
Hammurabi and his dynasty and we'll see
that they also have a connection to the
Hittites so this will hopefully acquaint
you with time these are Bronze Age
civilizations the state of the art of
Technology for most of the them was
bronze which is combining copper and tin
and you can make weapons and tools and
jewelry with it now what's interesting
about the Hittite is that they were one
of the first to start to use iron iron
required a little bit more technology in
order to melt iron you have to get the
furnace to be even hotter and the
Hittites we know did make use of iron
now they are also known as great charity
charioteers this is an image of what a
Hittite chariot will look like and so
with the combination of iron chariots
they that's one of the things that help
them establish something of an empire
now I mentioned that they come into
conflict with many other peoples in fact
they come into conflict with most of the
folks that you see on this on this
picture over here the first time that
you really see them in in a significant
way conquering things is in 1595 BCE and
this would be the old Hittite Kingdom
but this is what famously ends
Hammurabi's dynasty the amaura dynasty
in Babylon right over here they go to
Babylon in 1595 BCE and they overthrow
it they're not able to maintain rule
they have to go back there start to be
fragmentation dissension at home but
it's the end of the amorite and then
eventually another group the catfights
take over this region and you can see
them in grey right over here now what's
also interesting in this timeline that
we have it we're talking about hundreds
of years it's important to keep things
in perspective
is that you see that a lot of these
civilizations in the Middle East and
Mesopotamia this area is often referred
to as the Levant it's referred it's it's
related to the word Levante from Italian
for to rise because for it for the
Romans for the European for those in the
West this is where the Sun rose this was
the East it was the eastern
Mediterranean and so you have all of
these civilizations that are in the
Levant in the 14th century BCE and the
13th century BCE but then they start to
decline and that general period after
the or around the 12th century BCE is
known as the Bronze Age collapse when a
lot of these civilizations become a lot
more fragmented now I've already alluded
to the fact and I talked about this in a
lot of detail in the ancient Egypt video
that the chief rivals of the Hittites or
were the Egyptians and vice-versa
and it's particularly the case in the
14th and 13th centuries where both of
them were quite powerful empires you
have the Egyptians moving up into this
area right over here modern-day Israel
and Lebanon and you have the Hittites
moving down from the north from Anatolia
into modern-day Syria and there's a
whole series of conflicts that are mad
that emerge in this area and one of the
most famous and one of the most
significant happens in 1274 BCE and that
is the Battle of Kadesh Kadesh is a is
an area that has switched hands multiple
times between the Egyptians and the
Hittites at this time you have Ramses
the second considered the greatest
Egyptian pharaoh he is the pharaoh he is
the ruler of Egypt and he wants to
recapture Kadesh and what's significant
about the Battle of Kadesh it's the
earliest battle where we have a
significant account of the tactics of
the strategy of the formation of the
troops we know that there are over
50,000 soldiers involved it's currently
believed it might be the largest chariot
battle in an olive-oil history that we
at least know about and the actual
outcome of the Battle of Kadesh seems to
be a stalemate our accounts of it come
prime
early from the Egyptians we don't have
any or we don't have any significant
Hittite surviving accounts of the Battle
of Kadesh but it gave us a lot of
information but beyond just the battle
itself being significant because we have
this detail about what battles were like
at that time period with chariots and
and the type of tactics that were used
what's also significant is sixteen years
after the Battle of Kadesh you have the
Egyptian Hittite peace treaty in 1258
BCE and the reason why this is
significant is this is sometimes
referred to as the first peace treaty in
history I would qualify a little bit of
saying it's the first peace treaty that
we know about in this part of the world
and this right over here is the Hittite
version of it and what's especially cool
about this peace treaty and just you
know what these other pictures are this
is a Hittite ramp discovered at the
Hittite capital of hot osa this is some
pictures of the Hittite gods of the
underworld but once again we don't have
as complete of a picture of the Hittite
verses say the Egyptians but what's neat
about also neat about this treaty it's
sometimes called the Treaty of Kadesh
but it doesn't refer directly to Kadesh
these folks have been in conflict with
each other for nearly for over a hundred
years right over here so this treaty is
really to talk about not just Kadesh and
this treaty happened sixteen years after
the Battle of Kadesh but to talk about
let's just have a permanent peace
between our two great empires and what's
cool about it is we have surviving
accounts from the Hittites that were
discovered in Catoosa and we also have a
symmetric account that we get from the
Egyptians and so that's this is the one
from the Hittites and this is from the
Egyptians it's written in Akkadian which
wasn't their language Akkadian we talked
about was a Semitic language and they
use that cuneiform script which remember
we get from the Sumerians but it's cool
to get the same treaty written in
different scripts from both sides of the
conflict and I'll just read a little bit
of it because it's neat to just think
about it and of course they didn't write
it in this language modern English
wouldn't show up for many actually
thousands of years from this point this
is a translation now from the beginning
of the limits of eternity as for the
situation of the great rule
of Egypt with the great prints of Hattie
the God did not permit hostility to
occur between them through a regulation
but in the time of mullah Tallis the
great prints of Hattie my brother so
this is from the point of view of
hakushi Ellis who is the hittite king at
the time of the treaty he fought with
Ramses Mary Amman the Pharaoh Ramses the
great ruler of Egypt but hereafter from
this day behold ha to sillas the great
Prince of hoti is under a regulation in
order not to permit hostility to occur
between them forever that's that's those
are big words
well hold Hattusa list sometimes it's
spelled hot to silly the Great Prince of
Hattie has set himself in a regulation
with loser Mott ray set up an r/a that's
sometimes how how ran Jesus referred to
the great ruler of Egypt the beginning
from this day to cause a good peace and
Brotherhood occur between us forever
while he is in brotherhood with me and
he is at peace with me and I am in
Brotherhood with him and I am in peace
with him forever
behold I as the great Prince of Hattie
am with Rameses Miriam owned in good
peace and in good Brotherhood the
children of the children of the Great
Prince of Hattie are in Brotherhood and
peace with the children of the children
of Rameses Miriam owned the great ruler
of Egypt for they are in our situation a
brotherhood and an end and our situation
of peace the land of Egypt with the land
of Hattie shall be at peace and in
Brotherhood like unto us forever
hostilities shall not occur between them
forever so not only are they and this is
just part of the text line it's actually
quite interesting do a web search for
the Egyptian Hittite treaty text and you
can actually get the whole text this is
just part of an excerpt of it but they
go into much more details about how they
might provide aid for each other how
they're not going to have conflict etc
etc so I'll leave you there but it's the
important thing to take away is is some
of these modern notions of peace
treaties and military tactics they go
deep into history and this is some of
the earliest evidence we find but I
would suspect as we discover more things
we might find even earlier evidence